hi cool so my name is Brian Holt
currently working at Netflix and this is
the most ill-advised talk I've ever
given in the sense that there's so many
moving technology pieces that something
is Brown to bound to break and I'm
excited to find out which one it is
so my first ill-advised piece is I'm
going to be giving a talk out of the
command line because that's a good idea
throughout this entire talk please feel
free to tweet at Jas Kampf is there's
going to be several poll questions and
you can answer them and they should
magically appear up here first one is
what's your favorite framework of choice
and looks like people are already
tweeting react I think that's just
because that's the name of the talk so
whatever deal with it cool so I'm going
to talk about react and the idea of
learn once right anywhere and this is
kind of struck me while is reading their
Docs one day that the idea of learned
once right anywhere most of us are
familiar with PhoneGap or cordova or
ionic or any one of these particular
frameworks that are trying to be write
once run anywhere and to me that's kind
of a pipe dream so that's why I kind of
latched on to react learn once write
anywhere so let's talk a little bit I'm
yeah I'm Brian Holt whatever no one
cares and I work at Netflix which is a
pretty great I like wasting all of your
time and by where I used to work before
Netflix was reddit so I really like
wasting your time
cool so let's uh let's chitchat a sec
about react first of all if you ever
moment if you went to a Linds talk it
was fantastic about performance I gave
you a little bit more high-level if
you're not intimately familiar with
react so it's a library for creating
views and that's kind of like just the
high level that's exactly what react is
for it was created for the Dom I'm not
mistaken was created at Instagram and
then just kind of slowly took over
everything in the entire world including
Netflix Facebook Firefox what else is
out there lots of things are now being
written and react super super great
library it's a pattern for writing you
eyes and so we kind of got stuck with
MVC as front-end developers right like
MVC is super awesome for the backend if
you ever written Ruby on Rails Django
like that kind of abstraction of MVC
Model View controller works really
really well hey looks something like the
backbone go team so it works really
really well for the for the backend like
this this separation of concerns if you
have the models to talk to the database
you have the views that actually talk
out to the clients and if the thin
little controllers that kind of wire all
your data about this works super well
for for back-end programming and then
people that was like this is an awesome
idea I'm going to apply this to to the
Dom and it turned out that it's actually
not such an awesome idea if anyone's I
maintained a huge backbone app before it
can fall apart at the seams sometimes
there are great backbones out backbone
apps out there but you have to be very
disciplined to get them to work well so
some daring individuals decided to look
at this and said there has to be a
better way we should write a paradigm
that's specifically for writing UI
libraries and so they kind of came up
with this idea of request/response right
because that's kind of what the web has
been like for four years right like you
request a web page and you get back a
web page that's kind of the idea so they
have to say well we can kind of
generalize this abstraction and
apply it to more of a JavaScript
framework so they kind of came with this
idea of given a set of state so I'm
going to throw in state and I'm going to
get an output of abdomin ever my user
interface time I'm looking for this
ended up being really really great and
then they came up with a bunch of crazy
ideas of like how they can implement it
like the virtual DOM and crazy [ __ ] like
that but in the end of that you actually
don't have to care whenever you're
writing react for the most part you
don't really have to care how it's doing
it you just have to write your cosign
given this set of state my output looks
like this while JavaScript and go team
okay so let's take a second to talk
about what exactly is going on with this
craziness up here this is written for a
library called blessed did anyone check
out ken wheelers web packed dashboard
anyone see that come up on Twitter yeah
super cool right same library I used it
first though so suck on a Ken
I hope he's watching the live feed so
I'm gonna herd it curses right like this
is blessed
right that's instead of being cursed as
its blessed it's a it's a dumb joke but
that's what they went with so blessed is
a you can write user interfaces for the
command line using node right that's all
blessed is and then someone's thoughts
like well I mean we're writing user
interfaces why can't we point react at
that so that this actually is written in
react blessed so I wrote a user
interface for the command line using
react which is pretty awesome so I was
able to use all the same tools that I
used for the Dom use Babel whatever and
I was able to target the command line
using react which i think is pretty cool
so yeah let's go back to to talking
about react for just just a moment here
actually JK lol we're gonna go back for
just a sec so most of us are have worked
with react before or these sort of
familiar with it and there's two
packages here there's react and there's
react Dom right and this is kind of
confusing for newcomers to the
to the react world because they're
thinking I don't understand why I need
both these packages i have i want to
write react and I want it to render out
to the Dom that's kind of way it started
right up and through til react point
1314 something in that area
those were the same package you just
downloaded one react and it just worked
and then these crazy people over
Facebook's like let's write react and
have it target iOS and Android and so
they started writing these react
components that instead of targeting the
Dom they started targeting native
platforms and so they realized like
we're using the same paradigms using the
same lifecycle methods all these
different pieces that are built straight
into react they're regarding real react
components and just that last mile right
the last mile of delivery was the only
part that difference so they decided
like let's break out the part that
actually writes it out to the Dom call
that react Dom and now we have this
generalized react library that it
doesn't actually care what it's
targeting it just makes components right
it's just a way of declaring the way
that your components should look and now
we can do things like react native and
react blessed and all these other crazy
things that people shouldn't do but are
gonna do anyway like this talk so that's
what that's what react blessed is that's
what react Dom is is that's these last
mile libraries and that's kind of what
this talk is about is all the crazy
awesome stuff you can do with the react
library just by swapping out that last
mile cool so yeah let's go back to
talking about why react is so cool and
why is kind of took off right like it's
the new shininess that everyone's
talking about
half these conference talks are about
them like if you write angular or
empress Peschel if you write ember
you're probably sick about hearing about
react but let me tell you still why it's
cool it's about creating components and
that's for me that's kind of the bottom
line like you instead of having these in
in terms of UI development arbitrary
separation of concerns we decided to
take all the concerns for very small
pieces and then just mush them all
together in just this unholy matrimony
which ends up being really
great I'm doing a great job selling it
so you take all these components and are
these concerns and you mash them all
together for these very small components
but what's really really awesome by
smashing all these concerns together if
you're looking at your you know webpage
and say like the the login buttons
broken like the text is wrong or
something like that let's pretend for a
second that this is angular and I pick
on angular just because it's the one I
know the best but lots of frameworks
have had this problem before it could be
a jQuery app it could be just a plain
vanilla GIS app you look at it you see
the button text is wrong and you think
okay I have a bug where is my bug I
don't know if it's angular it could be
the directive it could be the controller
it could be the template it could be the
template for the directive it could be
one of the many services that you
decided to inject it could be the
library that brought it in right like
there's just all in other words you have
no goddamn clue where it is right just
by knowing that you have a bug you are
not really not much closer to finding it
now what's nice about react if you see
the component has a problem with it the
problem is in the component like it just
has to be there because all the concerns
lived there now I'm simplifying a tiny
bit right like I guess it could come
from like a ie user interface library
that that you are using in conjunction
or something something to that effect
but my point still stands that you have
a very very good intuition of where it
lives and you have at least the
beginning of the trail to go find what's
wrong with it and I think that's having
a beginning point when finding a bug is
already a huge step up so yeah it's a
pattern for creating user interfaces
that's what react is is a pattern for
user interfaces and other communities
started eyeing this and say like this is
really great like I like this
declarative method of declaring my
components saying kind of this reactive
way of saying okay given the set state
and these props need to change will I
pass down to my children it just made
sense and not only does it make sense
for the Dom it makes sense for a lot of
user interfaces as you can see here this
was really easy to write this didn't
take me
very many lines of code that I wrote an
entire presentation giving kind of piece
of [ __ ] let's be totally honest but I
wrote this with not too many lines of
code now if I asked you today to go out
and know today and write user interfaces
for the command line first of all you'd
be like why the secondly it'd be kind of
hard to get started with that but using
react this was actually really easy like
I don't have to know anything about
writing for the command line and to be
honest I really don't know that much
about it but I know a lot about writing
react because I've been doing it for a
long time and I was able to knock this
out super fast because I was able to
take that those same things I had
learned for writing react to the Dom
read writing react for native and
actually even at Netflix were writing it
for on TVs ps4 is Xbox is that kind of
stuff I was able to take those same
learnings and apply here and I think
that's that's pretty powerful I was able
to target a platform that I really don't
know too much about which is pretty
fantastic so again this is not the dream
of write once run anywhere right I can't
take this same code and try and run in
the browser I can't run it on a TV
that's that's not a useful target at
least in terms of the technology in my
opinion available today to us however
the idea that I can learn this paradigm
once and then apply it in many places
very very fascinating to me and so far
has pretty well held out in fact react
in terms of its ecosystem today is very
much about in embracing the differences
in all the different platforms if you're
writing react native for Android you're
encouraged to if you need to drop into
the Java layer in you know knock out a
couple pieces and then have that plug
back in to react native those are scape
hatches they're not only like available
but they're encouraged and the same
thing with react Dom if you need to you
know in component in mount and reference
the window bringing a jQuery plug-in for
who else who knows why I wouldn't
suggest it but if you need to do it you
can do it right and so it's about
embracing the differences in the
platforms so let's let's just take a
little sidetrack to JSX
let's be honest about people that wrote
react who do not write react at first
because I had JSX
this guy this guy right here I saw JSX
and I was like this is dumb like I just
got JavaScript out of my HTML I sure as
hell I'm not puttin HTML in my
JavaScript like that was that was my
reaction when I first saw that blog post
come out from Facebook like you guys
just go write your PHP your special PHP
and leave me alone and then I came back
like a year later as like [ __ ] I was
wrong this is actually really great so
let's talk about like what is jsx it
basically lets you write eight XML like
syntax aka
HTML for the most part directly in your
JavaScript and it's really just syntax
sugar for that just transpile x' two
function calls that's 100% of what JSX
is but the reason why I like it is I'm
writing code to mimic markup right like
ultimately that's what I want to do I
want to write code that ends up being
markup so if I'm writing code that's
going to end up being markup wouldn't it
be great if I could just write the
markup right and just get that kind of
middle step so that's what JSX aims to
be is like you're trying to get HTML
ultimately output to the Dom so just
write the HTML and then they'll
transpile it into something that
actually really works in JavaScript and
for the most part introducing a build
stuff is not really a problem anymore
because most of us are using Babel right
most of us most of us want to be using
Babel if we're not already using Babel
so introducing another plugin that
transforms your JSX
typically not not a problem so if you
are holding out still because of JSX I
suggest one everyone that I know that
writes react eventually ends up on jsx
with one exception but he's kind of
weird so it's cool but just give it a
shot and if you really really don't like
it it's actually pretty easy to write
react without JSX
it kind of sucks because it's like not
many tutorials because again most people
end up writing JSX
but if you want to learn then come talk
to me we can definitely figure it out
together and the other thing I like
about JSX is it's very declarative right
you're declaring I want my markup to
look like this
and I that also very appealing to me
like I much as possible I think
declarative code is easier to read
easier to reason about easier to
maintain all those things which in my
opinion make it empirically better that
doesn't really make sense anyway so last
thing has actually had written this I
but I didn't want to bring it to Iceland
so I didn't
so there's another library called react
hardware that you can write react for
the Arduino which is like right like
mind blown but you can actually like you
know turn on the breadboard and you know
blink the lights all that using just
react which is just fascinating to me
that someone took the time to do this
but it was super fun to write so all of
this to say is it's really really cool
stuff going on with react and I invite
you to give it a shot so I'm going to
move to the second part of my
presentation and we're going to now go
into the react Dom so where are you from
feel free to tweet that out
hopefully my server still running
so yeah react Dom is most prevalent
today that's kind of what react was
created for and everything else is kind
of trying to capture that magic that we
already have with react it's being used
at Netflix it's being used at reddit
Facebook Google Mozilla everyone is
using it to build interfaces and it's
pretty pretty sweet yeah I have here my
notes it's scales which i think is just
like the most [ __ ] thing to say I
don't even know what that means but it
scales what that might mean is that it's
really easy to use in teens because you
can treat components like I write a
component and you write a component and
they can kind of be black boxes to each
other with the way that react works they
kind of expose this like API is like
okay I expect you to give me these
things and I'm going to do things with
them right and there's secret things you
don't you don't get to know what it does
right which is can you I mean you can
look at the code but you don't have to
know what it does and I think that's
that's pretty awesome that you can treat
your
colles coat is as a block box that can
be scary too if you don't trust your
colleague but then you have other
problems I suppose so let's talk about
like what this might look like so this
is kind of a typical react app that you
might see right that you have these
interior like drop down components and
then you have like an author panel I
don't even know if this is supposed to
be a graduate of Google image search but
it's it's a component made up of other
components that is then inside of
another component which is then inside
another component right so it's just
components inside of components inside
of components but like something you
might notice which is really cool I have
a couple of dropdowns right here and
then I also have a drop down over here
or I have like a date picker over here
like I write these little components and
then I'm able to just use them across
the site my favorite example of that is
I used to work at reddit and you can
think about a reddit post right and a
reddit post you can give gold you can
upvote you can down vote you can report
to the admins you can give a permalink
there's all these different behaviors
that are commonly associated with posts
no matter where you put them right it
could be embedded into another page it
could be on the comet view it could be
on the home page it could be on a
subreddit view all these different pages
that display the same component well
it's kind of annoying to have to either
copy and paste these you know the
JavaScript associated with these all
these behaviors that also have to come
with the markup and all the styling and
all that kind of things the nice thing
about react is I write this drop-down or
this reddit post and I'm able to embed
it in all these different places and it
brings with it all of its styling it
brings with it all of its behavior it's
very you know dry do not repeat yourself
kind of an idea and I think that's a
pretty awesome in fact what you're
seeing here is another presentation
crazy thing that I decided to write oh
you can't see that what there I swear
there are
see there are things down here people
are tweeting we're just going to leave
it like this right this is readable no
okay well I promise there's a whole row
and they're very pretty and I can see
them it's mostly Iceland let's see it
was like seven Iceland tweets five us
ones three world ones and yeah that's it
oh yeah
so tweet some more than you can say
it'll make another row on top of it
props down action up so this is really
what kept me in react the idea with
react is this idea of one-way data flow
which is this amazing idea of parents
passed down pieces of data and callbacks
to the children and the children can
read them and they can call the
functions but they can't actually modify
them they're read-only they're mutable
to the child which means that if there
is a problem with that state it means
the child didn't muck with it because a
child simply cannot muck with it and
that really reduces your surface area
for bugs and I hope you're kind of
getting a theme here that react is very
maintainable it's very easy to track
down these bugs and I think it's a
really compelling reason to use react so
you pass down these props but when the
child has like some sort of event right
like if say it's that date picker that
we were just looking at it needs to
inform the parent container that
something happened
well the parent just passes down an up
callback the child says hey something
happened here's the data I got you deal
with it right and then it passes that
data but back up to the to the parent
and the parent is able to modify its own
data so if there's any problem with that
modified data the parent did it right
because only the parent can do it which
I also think is pretty compelling it's C
I know what I can do I can just unmask
amaizing
there you go now you can see it another
favorite part favorite part I have about
react is that the best practices for
react are usually just JavaScript best
practices and I think this is kind of a
bold assertion to make because I'm in
subtly implying kind of on purpose that
that's not necessarily true of other
frameworks but the nice thing about
reactors it's knowable you can know
everything about react there's just it's
not very big in terms of how many
methods there are I wish I probably
should have gone and counted but they're
not very many you can know the entire
API whereas is there anyone here
comfortable in deserting they used the
entire jQuery API in an app no hands no
hands okay no Liars in the room because
it's impossible there's like 300 methods
right and that do wildly different
things and so that's why I feel
comfortable and asserting that because
there's such a small API there's not a
whole lot to react and so most of the
stuff that you're doing on the
day-to-day is just writing raw
JavaScript which i think is also pretty
pretty damn compelling I talked about
this already react is definitely more
declarative you declare the way you want
your components to work we are kind of
posting those those blanks for you and
reactors community whoo look at that
hold on we're going to take a picture
wait where is there it is that [ __ ] is
getting tweeted
so I was trying to find like a picture
from your act calm save image as that's
embarrassing
okay so react his community
and I was trying to find a picture of
react comp and I couldn't find it so I
decided to take one of you all react is
a great community and the other thing
that's reactors community is this is a
webcam component that I did not program
but stole from NPM thank you 8m p.m. and
it had everything built-in like it I
took that screenshot and have to do
anything that was already built in so
there's also a community of people that
will help you out so yeah go team and
react as a fad absolutely like anyone
that's not telling you that is totally
deluding themselves like obviously its
new shiny right now we had new shiny
angular a couple years ago and we had
backbone knockout quit anyone still
writing quit I'm sorry just but I think
the lessons that we're taking here from
react are going to to live with us for a
long time this idea of one-way dataflow
is going to live with us for a long time
we're going to take a lot of these
lessons and apply them to our future
frameworks or to our future user
interfaces and so in that sense writing
react today I think is still a good
thing because you're learning good
practices of how to write maintainable
large apps in production all those sort
of great things so I have my yet most
probably terrible idea
for a demo but we're going to do right
now all right so I got to open QuickTime
here
I had it open didn't I nope okay
QuickTime and new movie recording yeah
maybe cool alright so this is also
written in react this is written by RS
using a technology called that's not
what I wanted to do called a frame and
look at that look at those pretty people
alright and then just put this into
Google glass right here alright so if
you let's try refreshing this page
actually
so a frame is a really cool tech that I
believe live was her name was talking
about this morning it's a technology
from our good friends at Mozilla that
they're going to save the world from
everyone there we go so if you tweet
that should come up there I think I
would imagine that would be
yeah it looks like it's still working so
I know absolutely nothing about 3d
programming like zero things but I was
able to write something in virtual
reality where it would take your picture
off of things you were tweeting and put
it in virtual reality like that is
stupid easy this is only like 100 lines
of code or something like that and I was
able to do that just using technology
using the same things that I already
knew about writing react for a sign-up
process on Netflix I was able to apply
those same lessons and apply them into
3d so I think it's pretty cool and
pretty compelling I don't think this is
letting people tweet which is
disappointing but nonetheless I promise
you it does actually work let's see if I
can actually just do it on here I'm
almost out of time anyway so
there we go Oh looks like someone is
tweeting so yes we have to learn once
right anywhere it is a real thing if you
take the time to learn react and I think
these lessons that were you learning now
with react community are going to
service into writing user interfaces for
a long time so thank you